[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q and a segment number 56
we are ready to address the burning
questions that you have submitted
through super chat and if you haven't
submitted them yet you still can that's
right
you certainly can i cannot see my
computer though so
we don't have any questions nope we will
figure something out toot sweet
lickety-split well i got sent
well zack figures this out i got sent
the discord question for this week
on my phone so i will look at that
first if i can find it nope that's not
where it is
okay it just was so here's here's the
discord question here we go
um we're going to start with this
question this week from the discord
wait can you see it on the screen yep
sure can
but still we're gonna start with the
discord question because i pulled it up
in light of the various existential
threats that we face is authoritarianism
regardless of ideology
avoidable is there a way to do
authoritarianism in a non-ideological
non-tribal way
governing ai corporatism imperial
meritocracy something else
if unavoidable should we consider ways
to do authoritarianism ethically and
thoughtfully
ps person asking the question is not
pro-authoritarian just questioning
their assumptions i think i got it
okay i think i know what they mean go
for it um so i would draw a distinction
between authoritarianism
which is very very bad and coercion
which is a necessary evil um but the
idea is we should be
minimizing the amount of coercion
necessary to accomplish
things like reaching the
collective analysis for things like
public safety and public health
so anyway there's a certain amount of
coercion necessary but
basically authoritarianism is coercion
first
and uh a a better structure
involves recognizing that there are
times in which
one needs more than the normal amount of
coercion
uh you try to make it temporary you try
to make it as
harmless as possible but in any case i
think that's the answer
authoritarianism itself is effectively
the malignant version
of a system of government's governance
in which
coercion is playing an important role
which it always is
yeah it must good all right we're going
to answer a few questions from
last week's episode before moving on to
your questions from last hour before
then moving on to your questions from
this hour my
my 10 old my 10 year old twins like the
song on youtube from american rapper the
baby
which propagates blm rioters and
demonizes the police
how should i tell them this is wrong
without being patronizing
so i did not i pulled this from last
week but i did not look up the song so i
don't i don't know anything about it but
i don't think we need to
um to to address this question how to
talk to your 10 year olds
about them being sucked into uh an
ideology that
seems like it's all goodness and light
but really isn't yeah i mean
you know i think this um the right
answer to this question
borrows from the approach we took with
our own kids from the very beginning
and the approach that we took with
college students for
a decade and a half and the answer is
that you shoot above people's heads and
you
allow them to rise to meet you and so
you may have to simplify
language a little bit to reach a
ten-year-old but not all that much
not too much um and what i would say
i think is that there are real problems
with policing
and so it seems like by getting rid of
the police you would eliminate those
problems
and you would but the problem is that
there's a lot
that is produced by policing even when
policing
is not good the benefits of it are
effectively invisible
all the crimes that aren't committed
because people are afraid that they will
be
caught by the police and taken away are
invisible they just don't register until
you eliminate the police
and you discover that what you get is a
world of warlords
so i think i would tell the 10 year old
that the problem is
it's an overly simple solution that
getting rid of the police
seems like a solution to people who've
seen
uh abuses of power by the police but
that is only because they haven't seen
the alternative
which is worse and that the solution
actually involves
fixing policing rather than eliminating
it
yeah that's great i was going to add
some things but i think you did it
all right it seems that you think that
blm and bad science are eating the world
in the real world though i don't see it
happening what am i missing
you can't pay the rent with your waste
race or sex isn't reality unmovable
so that's i think that's a coherent set
of things although the
individual thoughts there um seem to be
going all over the place a little bit
but
i mean i think the basic question is in
in my world the person asking the
question
i'm not seeing uh the effects of black
lives matter
or of bad science on on
my on my lifestyle and my career on
anything
um i would say that you're lucky
and that many many people are and that
whether or not you can see it yet
doesn't mean that it's not having the
effects that those of us who are seeing
it
um say it does feel like you're
objecting no i i agree
i think i'm having a little trouble
imagining how
you could miss the hazard of it given
what it is demanding
um miss the hazard you said right i mean
for whatever
i mean if it was if it was a totally
fringe thing right right
and um it really was a couple of yahoos
and the mainstream media was actually
blowing it out of proportion instead of
completely minimizing it right
um then yeah you could
they could be doing exactly the same
thing and if it was five people
you know in each in a handful of cities
then why are we talking about something
sure
but you know we could and many did do
the same thing
with uh you know the
de-platforming that was going on on
college campuses and the point was
how serious actually is this the answer
is it's really goddamn serious and you
can now see that because it's driving
murder rates up inside of major cities
that are
run by uh democratic administrations
right so you know if death is bad
and murder tends to kill people then
it would seem that this is a serious
issue because lots of people are no
longer walking the earth who presumably
would have been uh but for this
um this tantrum yeah but you know the
last question
excuse me isn't reality unmovable um yes
certainly
the one of the central tenets at the
core of what we're talking about is that
there is an objective reality out there
whether or not
we will ever actually get to it but the
scientific method allows us to sort of
approach it as an
asymptote and we never know we only
occasionally will know under certain
circumstances how close we actually are
to the objective reality that's out
there that said
there was a lot about the human
experience that is not directly
reflective of the objective reality and
so
given that the for instance schools of
education at least the united states are
pretty well captured
by this kind of thinking and the
graduates of those schools will be going
out
uh and becoming k-12 teachers for
instance um
you know primary and secondary school
teachers what will it do
to a whole generation or whole
generations of children's minds who grow
up
thinking patently untrue things and with
no skills in their back pockets
with which to determine whether or not
what they're saying or thinking is
actually reflective of reality
um and so you know from there it's a hop
skip and a jump to we have engineering
schools
that are encouraging yeah i don't know
if it's there's actually queering of
engineering but
um you know there's a lot of bad rhyme
yeah um
but uh god many episodes ago we talked
about
some phd thesis in a in an engineering
school um
being being defended that was clearly
intersectional and you know
at the point that bridges start falling
down obviously you have
uh a direct conflict between
intersectionality
and and reality you know where civil
engineering just can't accommodate this
um but there's a whole lot of space
between
um you know totally social constructed
stuff over here
and you know does the bridge stand or
not and
the vast majority of where most of us
spend our time is in some place
hopefully a little bit closer to
um does the bridge stand or not but
there's still enough
interpretation by people of what it
means
um that whether or not their beliefs
reflect reality or not actually really
does matter
i also flatly disagree that you can't
pay the rent with your race or sex
um this is at this point this is clearly
one of the
uh the most actionable items on the
demand list is
you know they're going to create
positions where ostensibly the purpose
of the decision
the position is to
figure out what to do about diversity
equity and inclusion problems but of
course the position can only be
inhabited by somebody who meets the
criteria
and so um this is a way of skirting the
normal process
by declaring something necessary which
then
installs particular demographic
requirements associated with it right
and you know we're now seeing this in
you know with boardroom requirements and
all sorts of things so
yeah and whole divisions of of colleges
you know i'm
a i don't know about a majority a large
number and a growing number of colleges
and universities
at least in the us have not just
sort of departments dedicated to equity
and inclusion
but whole divisions of the college and
indeed this is this is not the time
place i'd have to go back and look at
the various numbers but
one of the things that happened at
evergreen was exactly
the um downgrading of academics
as one of originally four divisions of
the college yes academics was only one
of four
um but the other the other three were
reasonable there was basically student
affairs which is everything to do with
um you know housing and food and clubs
and
health care and you know all of this and
there was um
basically finance and administration you
know the all the
all the running of the college that
included things like the physical plant
and then there was
um i don't remember the names of them
but effectively um outreach pr
right um which you know looked to alums
and looked to the public and looked
outside for
you know how it is that you get money
that's not coming from the state so
academics of course
is what the core of a college university
is or should be
should be um but even in its original
formulation at evergreen which is just
the system we know best it was only one
of four
um most universities which are just
colleges that have phd granting
authority
they're bigger there are presumably more
divisions than that
but one of the things that the not so
hapless
but um you know perhaps intent on
destroying the college president at
evergreen did
was demoted academics and created
two new divisions of the college
including one and again i don't know
exactly what it's i don't remember
exactly what it's called because i don't
have my notes up here right now but a
diversity equity inclusion
vice president and all of the staff
accompanying that so whereas before
there had been four vps
academic student affairs finance and
admin or whatever in
public relations or whatever it was
called now there was additionally
a vp at the same level for equity and
inclusion which
yeah extremely highly paid with you know
in the hierarchy of
physicians somebody who did not have
lots of experience as somebody who
jumped a bunch of levels and was
suddenly being paid uh you know hundred
thousand dollars
plus a year more than that but it was it
was a lot of money for evergreen in
particular
um and the and and they needed to staff
her entire
right right every and and you don't you
don't staff those positions
either without while being blind to
things like race and sex and that's
that's an abomination yeah and so in
that case that was bridges falling down
on the job
yeah that was that was my line dude oh
did you say that something well actually
not bridges fallen
falling down the job i referred to
faculty trolls hiding under bridges yes
yes there you go yes so sorry it's a
redux but yeah but it's
different yeah it's different um so in
any case
uh yeah the final thing um
that i would say there is just think
back to what we were talking about in
the first hour
with respect to the university of
chicago and what it's doing to english
that's a career path that is now being
uh
explicitly narrowed to people who only
espouse
one interest and presumably one
perspective on it
um so anyway yes you can very definitely
pay the rent with this stuff
and that's a hazard to everything else
that should be
rewarded yep next question
uh from episode 55 how can one combat
claims that all regularly occurring
climate events such as wildfires are
related to man-made climate change
without coming off as a denier
to this i would just say i looked back
and figured out which episodes we
actually talked about this in it was
episodes 44 and 45 back when we were
enduring you know basically smoke lock
down the smokopolis
uh in the pacific northwest that had us
had portland
having the worst air quality in the
world there for 8 or 10 days
so we specifically talked about what
fraction of the wildfires and their
intensity was being attributed
to anthropogenic climate change by the
by the really careful people who were
not just
um stated you know having planted a flag
either in everything is climate change
or nothing is climate change
we were really trying to figure out what
it was and as i remember in this
particular case the intensity
in both the increase in number and the
intensity of the fires that are
happening in the pacific northwest being
somewhat different range from some of
the other western um
biomes in which fires are happening was
something like a third i think 30 to 40
or maybe 30 to 50 percent
is what it was which is both substantial
and not everything and it is that's
exactly what it is
right i you know i would this is yes
based on models and we have questioned
the models before but
um so many models point to that kind of
nuanced understanding of what is going
on
um and that is a broad enough span um
that i would
i would i sit pretty confidently with
those numbers
yeah then i i would just point back to
the first
hour also um you know this is another
one of these things
that even a good education tends to lack
now so on the same list with population
versus individual level thinking and
collective action problems
there is a basic lack of understanding
of how to process
uh complex noisy systems
and how to understand them and to
recognize pattern in them and you know
we are forever tripping over the fact
that you can't
prove that a given event has such a
cause but you can deduce it that it's
likely that it does exactly so anyway
that that is uh
something to be upgraded in our
educational structure too if we ever
decide to rebuild it that would be great
yeah and i
i don't remember if i said it so that
was episodes 44 and 45 where we talked
about this
somewhat as well a
comment that i appreciated so i thought
i'd read it thanks to both of you for
what you do to counter those who would
tell others to sit down and shut up
thank you for standing up for language
and science and liberty
thank you for that yeah stand up and
shut down instead
or i don't know oh latter day timothy
leary
not i'm working it's a prototype
what talents are not well represented on
a resume what new heuristics would you
like to see
standardized that could expand across
that expand access to white-collar jobs
i am passionate about helping underdogs
compete
so this is a great question to which i
did not actually
think through what the answers might be
but it's something that i think we
should return to
perhaps at some length but do you have
something at the top of your head here
yep i do i
fear that i may be borrowing it from
david
kelly the uh stanford professor and
engineer that
i think i mentioned once before um and
if i'm not borrowing it from him then
i'm sure it's something he'd agree with
um but
it is the importance
no the meaning if you encounter somebody
who has a habit of
tinkering right somebody who constructs
little mechanisms or takes things apart
and
fix them fixes them troubleshoots them
such a person
tends to be uh very capable of
navigating all kinds of systems
that are you know not explicit in other
words
a ability to open up a machine that
isn't working
and troubleshoot hypothesis test all the
things you need to do in order to get it
to
possibly work tends to be good in all
kinds of situations where those skills
are are also valuable so and where if
you have not succeeded you cannot argue
with the thing in question and convince
it that you have succeeded
right the physical reality of the of the
system
trumps the social reality of what you
want to be true
yes although there's one caveat buried
under that which is
um you know this was very much my
experience as a kid
tinkering and i later read feynman say
almost exactly the same thing about his
experience as a kid which is
that very often if you take something
apart and you know when you take apart
almost anything complex these days you
don't understand how it works
you're looking at circuit boards rather
than lovers right and even if it's
levers the stuff
is often so complex that it's hard to
track right
but it doesn't mean there's not a lot
you can deduce about what's inside but
here's the
the funny odd fact which is
you've got some object that doesn't work
you take it apart looking for a problem
sometimes you can spot it sometimes you
can't
but if you just work on the skill of
taking it apart without losing anything
and taking it apart so you don't destroy
anything and so you can get it back
together
very frequently on putting it back
together it does work
and so the lesson that i derive from
this is
that something will be out of place and
the logical ability to put things back
where it seems they must go because
almost always there's
only one place each part could go you
know short of a screw or something like
that yeah there's only one place each
part could go
and so just simply learning to take
things apart and put them back together
without doing any harm
actually allows you to fix a bunch of
things so it's not like you've convinced
it to work
but you did fix it without fully
deducing what was not working exactly
you didn't you you did not
you made it functional without doing the
diagnostics um or without successfully
doing the diagnostics even though you
were interested in
doing so um and you know and this but
this also reveals something about the
nature of physical systems which is that
things where
things slide slightly out of place and
that you know those
those two observations things where
things slide out of place are not the
complete solution set to why that will
work
but it certainly is going to be some of
the times right like you just have
something with a lot of
moving parts or parts that are moving
but aren't supposed to be moving take
them apart you put them back in
securely you know add you know add add
lubrication where there should have been
someone there wasn't you know take out
the lubrication where it had gotten
where it should where it doesn't belong
and you put it back together and voila
okay i don't know what it was that was
sliding when it shouldn't sticking when
it shouldn't
slightly in the wrong place had slipped
etc um but
it looks like given that it's working
now that that is probably going to have
been the case
and then and then you can continue you
can you can track like okay does it fail
again
the same way within a week a month never
you know so you know is is the piece in
question of the larger functional system
itself about to fail such that you can't
make it work by putting it back together
or was it just loose is it is it just uh
something that happened that doesn't
need to be understood for you to move
forward with a functional system
absolutely but even just the skill
of opening something and putting it back
together without doing harm to it
trains the mind it's surprisingly hard
right lots of things like once they're
open you see how they were supposed to
be opened but you can't see that there
was a little tab that you were supposed
to you know
push or something like this without
breaking it so something you know
sometimes you do
when i when i was a kid my rule was if
it's broken
then i'm licensed to take it apart
because i'm not going to make it worse
right and so
is that a rule that you shared with your
parents um
i think so i mean it you know the point
is it was an obvious rule because it was
stuff that was
sure headed to the track i mean it
sounds like a reasonable role it just
also sounds like the kind of role that
at least some parents i don't think
yours
um would have objected to just on the
basis that it sounds like you're going
to start justifying that it's kind of
broken it's almost broken
well look it's broken this was the 70s
and 80s there was a lot of
broken gizmos around and a person could
spend a lot of time on them yeah but
i do wonder you know there are a lot of
things
that train the mind right
and there's presumably diminishing
returns on this
right if you train the mind all in one
way then you get less
of a an effective mind than if you had
two such
exercises but if you took some fraction
if you took half of some college and
instead of putting them through the
course work of all of the philosophy and
and english and math and science that
they
were otherwise going to take and you had
them
take stuff apart for every hour that
they would have spent on other things
there'd be some stuff missing from that
education to be sure
would they in the end come out with a
more agile mind better able to pick up
the stuff that they didn't
catch that they actually need in other
words how would it compare
head-to-head would you get smarter
people out the other end yep
you know to which i would add um and you
know this is this is
the road down which you end up with you
know a two-full curriculum but to which
i would add
um representative art and craft
um you know some some version of
creating
creating a product in the universe that
is recognizable or useful recognizable
as the thing which you
wanted it to be recognizable as if
you're making representative art
or useful in some way and i you know
music has to fit in there somewhere but
i don't know exactly
how it fits in this particular rubric um
so that is another sort of thing that
everyone should have something
something creative artistic craftsmen
craftsmen like
um in their in their quiver of
of arrows whether or not
they understand or can explain why it is
that this will be useful in some
white-collar job
and then also um outdoor exploration
including
sport wherein you are interfacing not
you know
and you know there are a lot of there
are a lot of team sports that
most people have no interest in playing
and you know i i did play some team
sports growing up i played i played
volleyball
but ultimate is the one that we both
came to in grad school and played a ton
of and um that
allows you to interface both with the
physical world and with the social
nature of a team
and with competitors and with
collaborators and so you know it really
does just bring out a ton
of of remarkable skills that you know
there's
there's a reason that you're allowed to
put that sort of thing on a resume even
if nobody exactly knows what it's there
for
yeah i i agree with uh your additions
um and i like that you uh you said
representative art not that that's the
only
valid kind of course but it is possible
to fake your way through art if you are
not
required to demonstrate um an ability to
you know
cause the mind to think it's looking at
a you know a three-dimensional object or
something like this
in terms of 2d and 3d art i i think it
does
need to be representative sorry or you
have to have that skill it's not to say
that the higher
value might not come from something
abstract but the
part that trains the mind for sure yeah
is the part that causes you to say well
you know i i have a 3d model of what i'm
seeing
how can i create a 2d rendering that
causes the person who's looking at it to
have the experience
recognize that that's what i was trying
to do right so that
it's basically the check the social
check on whether or not your
understanding of the universe is
accurate
by some by some measure similarly craft
you know be it weaving or
pottery or woodworking or you know any
metal working any number of things
there is a result that not everyone will
love but
is it is beautiful by some standards and
functional
and um it either his or it isn't right
which i think is why museums are full of
still lives
right it's not that a bowl of fruit is
um such an awesome
subject full of meaning um but the point
is
it's bowl of fruit right well we know
what it's supposed to look like hey
maybe
i don't even know if this is true all
right you are people you're going to
tell me
right there's something about a bowl of
fruit
at least before the invention of
photography where
if you can render a bowl of fruit you
are painting at a certain rate
right either you're doing it before the
fruit melts in the bowl
yeah right sure or your memory is really
good
and that's another extraordinary skill
and so in some sense you practice on
something like this that
isn't permanent and basically it sets a
higher standard for
what you're achieving oh that's
interesting i think i don't know if
either you or i have really spent much
time with art history
um but i wonder if that's not been
proposed somewhere in
what what a still life is about so it's
just still landscape
it's a little bit of that with
seasonality and such but no your
description of before the fruit melts in
the bowl
right is is really vivid yeah that's
right that's good
i'll be curious to see what we get back
on that yeah okay uh let's go to
the questions from last hour time is
running short
the failure of our education system is
the problem from which all other issues
arise
there needs to be an idw style meeting
of the minds to come up with a plan to
fix education get venture capital start
small grow
please so um i actually i have
i only rank ordered these and have not
had time to read any of them
um between our live streams today so i
did not realize that i'd put that
appropriately right after the previous
one so i feel like we've just talked
about some of the ways
um that that education could be fixed
i agree time is running short i do feel
like um
20 years ago neither you and or i would
have thought
that we would become educators precisely
right
we we were scientists you know i
specifically
also thought of myself very much as a
writer explorers adventurers
and you know perhaps academics but
educators not so much
and we became that quite explicitly and
quite wholeheartedly
at evergreen and um and
came i think in so doing
to really understand a lot about what is
wrong and what can be done
most of which much of which
maybe cannot be done with the current
system so much of the best of what
we could do at evergreen required
extended periods of time and the ability
to deep dive
with with people and a that's hard to
scale
and it's probably impossible to scale
into like an 800 person class
and it probably doesn't work if you're
jumping from class to class every 50
minutes
yes and then there is the gigantic
horsefly and the ointment of trying to
start something that even worked at the
right scale
which is that if you and i
we both think and we in fact worked for
a year on a project to see if there was
a way in
there is a way to fix education it would
be hard to do worse than we're doing
you know and you could do much better
much cheaper if you just simply
took the word of the relatively small
fraction
of the faculty that actually succeeds in
reaching people and
upgrading their minds but the problem is
were you to try to do it and escape all
of the garbage that has taken out now
100 of american higher ed institutions
right where you try to do that then what
you are
is either going to try to get accredited
and you're going to go down the same
rabbit hole as these other things
have or you're not going to be
accredited and now you're up against the
question of
what is this unaccredited you know is it
snake oil is it this is it that
so i think this is the perfect moment
for that because at some level the
bankruptcy
of the mainstream system is now becoming
relatively widely recognized and the
expense of it is so
stupidly out of proportion to what you
get that
you know if ever there was a moment at
which people might say yeah screw it
i don't care if it's unaccredited it's
high quality
right if there was ever a moment for
that this would be it but nonetheless
even even to the point of view of well
you're going to start an educational
institution and it's not going to have
an edu
domain or email edu email addresses
it's not going to be eligible for
funding from the federal government
through the same mechanisms because
of the lack of accreditation so
accreditation is that thing
uh that you you know you plug your
educational institution into
to make sure that it gets its lobotomy
um and
you know if you want to avoid it you pay
one set of costs if you want to embrace
it you'll pay the other and um
you know it's doable but the system is a
problem
yep next question would you please make
time to talk about ancient female big
game hunters at the beginning of your
next live stream
yes apologies we've talked about doing
it twice now and haven't gotten to it
i'll put it at the top
of the docket for next time uh
yeah we've got to talk about that before
it comes back into fashion
you think people are a big game hunter
you're worried a little
i'm not okay um
here we have a link to something that i
at least haven't seen
um why from lockdownskeptics.org the
future shape of things
jim our friend jim lindsey posted on
twitter so we'll take a look
and see if we have any thoughts next
week
next question heather a while ago i
think you had previously stated
something to the effect of quote
societies
that produce weak males will often
produce aggressive females
obviously not a direct quote but can you
expand on that
but i don't remember saying that but i
don't disagree
and i think the the opposite
well there's a causality here
that is the only thing that is
potentially not right
that i think if you have if you have a
society that has
weak members of either sex you're going
to have strong members of the other sex
and that doesn't that doesn't imply
causation
um you know so you know weak weak
females
in a society are probably going to be
correlated with aggressive strong males
and weak males probably correlated with
aggressive females but producing
aggressive females maybe i might
actually put the causality
um backward the other way around here as
well
that as um as you have more and more
frankly
male typical style of aggression
um among women um that
interestingly many you know men are more
and more likely to step down
and to to you know sort of be because
they're being threatened at some level
because they're being told that
uh this is no longer their time and
they're not allowed on the stage anymore
and of course you know as we've talked
about many times you know this
this ends up making men weak and of
course the women who are
often arguing that they need men to step
down and get off the stage and all of
this don't want weak men
and so this leaves men who have been
followed some path that they thought was
the right one left with very few options
and it it's not through no fault their
own it's part you know partially their
fault
they made choices but um you just
shouldn't
you shouldn't buy it when people claim
that what they want is weakness in their
partners you know weakness and their
potential partners and that's not what
anyone wants
and um you know there's a kind of
docility that some men may want in
some women but i would say women those
aren't the men you want
and there is you know it's just even
hard to imagine
what world men any men are imagining
that um
has women admiring and wanting to be
with life
for life with you know spineless men
there's no hysterical precedent for this
precedent right no
it won't work um i would add one thing
to this
which is the dimorphism
in males and females has resulted in
legal asymmetries which are justified by
the fact that women are actually
vulnerable to men in a way that is not
typically the reverse so those legal
advantages that go to women which are
compensatory can also be abused
and so one of the things that we are
seeing
is that women who are willing to make
use of the protections of women
as an offensive weapon are wielding it
which is causing
men to be at the very least
incoherent because they can't just
simply depend on the fact
that um you know if they're decent
they're they're not vulnerable
if accusations you know in in a world
where we're debating what you know
believe all women means or believe women
does it mean believe all women and
what does that who does that empower um
you know you've got weapons
that are not secured being wielded
against people that somebody wants to do
damage to and
you know it doesn't always result in the
right people being punished
so again it suggests that your
the causality being reversed here i
think is likely yeah and i would argue
that the uh
um the weaponization
boy you said something there that i
really wanted to respond to
i've now lost it um
damn okay we'll move on i just i can't
remember
i'd like to come back to it i'm gonna
make this in color here
um
do you have thoughts on this frank
herbert paraphrase
scratch a conservative and you find a
person who prefers a certain past to an
uncertain future
scratch a liberal and you find a closet
aristocrat
um i've never heard that before uh
the first part sounds right and i think
most conservatives
would grant that scratch conservative
and you find a person who prefers a
certain past to an uncertain future
the second half scratch a liberal and
you find a closet aristocrat
i don't immediately see how that is true
what do you what do you think well um
yeah i was gonna say the same thing that
the first part of this seems
clearer than the second part i think
what the second part is about
is that you know liberalism has
traditionally
had a um
a valence of fighting for
the underdog and so it's supposed to
collect
underdogs and combine them with people
who are advocating for their interests
so to the extent that one aspires to be
an aristocrat but you're not in a
position to do it
things like redistribution are appealing
and so i can see i think i think the
problem i have with it is that
if you scratch some liberals you will
find closet aristocrats
no doubt about that but i don't think
it's inherent to it yeah
good that makes sense uh and i thought
of the
other thing i just wanted to add to our
conversation there about um
uh strong women and weak men being
coincident in society
um which is that you you bring up the
weaponizing
of um important legal rights that women
have because of sexual dimorphism
um and you know very often when anyone
men or women talk about the
weaponization of those
rights by some women we are told that we
are being misogynists that we are acting
as
as if we don't care about about women
and i would say
actually that's exactly 100 wrong
that it is those women who would
weaponize
the laws that have been put in place to
protect women on account of the fact
that we are on
average smaller and have less muscle
mass who are themselves the misogynist
so they are working against the
interests of
all the rest of women and all the good
men out there as well that
that is the misogynistic position not us
criticizing them doing so
so i totally agree with that and i'm
imagining a deep fake in which
you and i talking about this is um
same set and everything but we're
guerrillas having this conversation
which frankly you can imagine reasonable
gorillas having this conversation
imagined you was a gorilla shirt well
sure why not um but i mean you know
it's a it's a it's a fine and
interesting uh
great ape and it's the diamorphism is
rather profound
rather the most poliginous right um and
for those
for those uh who aren't familiar with
the languaging here
polygyny is the very particular type of
polygamy
polygamy is the term that's usually used
but it always is actually
in common pile it's a stand-in for
peligeni meaning
a mating system in which one male
monopolizes the reproductive effort of
lots of lots of females right
on uh but the investment is high on the
part of silverback mouse but anyway i
just think it would be funny
you know a in some ways i find gorillas
more human than chimps yeah there's a
there's a humanness about them uh that's
more more relatable in some ways but oh
and there and i mean they
they keep the peace more frequently as
well rightly
no i think i think they're they're yeah
they are they're more peaceable to be
sure
by a lot um something to do with having
to spend so much of their day eating
leaves
actually it is is going to be diet
related not just mating system social
system
i think that's true yeah but anyway i do
think it would make
this very conversation the point would
be all the more effective
if i were also 50 smaller than you for
instance well right exactly but you know
the fact that you could have this
conversation
and that you know two people who are
interested in the analysis could arrive
at the same conclusion even though the
disadvantage
you know were you to weaponize it would
be you know
uh substantial so um anyway
we'll see the future may have the dark
horse podcast
uh gorilla version gorilla version
gorilla edition
all right um
this is a recommendation i think um
netflix
netflix's babylon berlin has been
amazing to watch and draw parallels to
regarding america right now in pre-nazi
germany
communist riots followed by national
backlash love to know what you draw from
it much love from new zealand
um i don't even know of it and we
haven't watched it have you heard of
this i've not heard of the series i've
heard this
parallel drawn um and so anyway i'm very
interested
to the extent that there is such a
series it's it's uh it's worth us
looking into
yeah i've heard both of you correctly
criticize the us voting process
but to what degree do you think the
current undermining by trump will
irrevocably pull voters out of elections
and or nudge us towards separatist
parties
well that's a tough one yeah um so two
different
possible outcomes as you've heard me say
uh the unity movement was very concerned
about this on the front end before we
had
a division over
how fair the election had been and
i do believe that the solution involves
us coming up with some system
that is modern and robust which would
arise out of the recognition
that we all benefit from such a system
and the problem is uh
frankly i think these parties like
cheating
and you know i'm not saying anything
about oh yeah
of course of course it's what they do
and
um that you know i'm not talking about
the balloting
itself but the point is i think there is
a reflexive desire
to keep the system you know baroque
because frankly
people are you know itching to gain
their advantage in a court fight over
hanging chads or whatever it is and
um really the fact is a lot of these
people don't believe in
democracy as a system they they like it
as a as a
as camouflage and those of us who
do think that the consent of the
governed is the sole basis for the
legitimacy of government
have to reassert structures that will
allow us to figure out what the public
wants even when the public wants
something that we at a lower level think
is bad
right the process either works or it
doesn't and those of us who believe
that it works better than the
alternatives
have to fight for it now i will say you
have to compare
the hazard of a modernized system in
other words a bad
modernized system would be almost
certainly more prone to fraud
versus a really well thought out
modernized system
so it's not like modern is inherently
better in this case modern could very
easily be worse but
good modern compared to our
completely bizarre and
highly irregular and variable
system that system is clearly prone
to error and if you were going to hide
something hiding it in a complex
phenomenon rather than a place where you
could track
individual um patterns
uh is obviously it's obviously a problem
yeah
uh also you had a gem hidden in there as
is so often
the case you you produce you produce
these phrases that
should be lasting which is that you said
that both parties are wearing democracy
as camouflage
uh that they that they like to pretend
that's what they do to to be democratic
but that it is a useful faint um to
direct attention to the democracy
sounding stuff and obscure what's going
on behind the scenes
yep such as the nature of duopoly
oh boy we're gonna read a few more from
here and then move to the following hour
what are the chances that you'll get ed
snowden on the dark horse podcast
second part of the question do you think
you should be pardoned
yes i think he should be pardoned i
agree ed snowden should absolutely be
pardoned
um would love to have him on the podcast
also believe that assange should be
pardoned uh and i
i hope that trump will do these things
on
on the way out of office yep also after
coveting so same person asking the
question
new question also after covet is over
would you be open to hosting small group
educational trips for people like us to
places of biological interest like you
did with your students
that's a crazy idea yeah so um
yeah we we've been talking about that
for a number of years and
in fact part of the reason um first to
go down to
to pattini this extraordinary biological
research station
in the heart of the ecuador and amazon
in january of 2020 of this year
was to assess whether or not it would be
really accessible whether or not it
would be at all plausible
to take people there and i think you
know the short answer is
probably um and um
the the experience of showing
people deep nature that they have only
seen
represented in you know animations or
highly curated nature documentaries in
the past
is really such a joy and being able to
do so along with
an education about what the evolutionary
processes that you're observing
the results of mean is even even more
fun so yeah i think
i i think we might yeah it's the best
and we should it's easier for me to say
because
um heather has gotten the logistics down
to a science and the logistics are not
fun
yeah so it's a tremendous amount of work
the logistics that i'd gotten down to
the science were with the help of an
admittedly
uh small and somewhat incompetent
college but um
they took care of for instance all the
legal parts of it
right yeah so i just had to make sure
that i and all my students were in
compliance i didn't have to
source anyway um
so it's more complicated than it might
seem but um possibly yes
um hi this is my first super chat but
i've been here since the beginning
could you speak about the new research
on hyperbaric oxygen therapy and the
increase in length of telomeres
thanks to all thanks to you all for all
you do
yeah i'm barely aware of this i'm highly
skeptical of the actual utility in other
words
i may be wrong but what i think i read
is that they are using these uh oxygen
enriched chambers and discovering
that telomere lengthening is
occurring now it is a stretch
though to infer that this is going to
create
a reversal of the senescence
pattern and for various reasons one of
them
i i argued in my paper which ultimately
came out
in was it 2002 it's 2002
that one of the key features that was
causing aging
i called it histological entropy
i should have called it epigenetic
entropy
did not yet understand that how that
term would
would change but in any case the point
is that
cells trigger different subsets of their
genomes they encode different proteins
at different stages in their
life cycle and that the
proper encodings are
triggered by information about where a
cell is that it gets from its neighbors
and the path that a cell has taken to
become what it is as it has become more
and more narrowly specified
and the problem is as you lose cells
from a mature
system and they are replaced by other
cells
the information on which the cell bases
its estimation of which genes it is
supposed to transcribe
becomes lower and lower quality in other
words the organization
of the epigenetic information becomes uh
noisy and as it becomes noisy cells are
doing
less of it tissues are doing less of a
good job because the cells within them
are not well organized relative to each
other and
there's no way that enriching oxygen
introduces any information into the
system
about what genes to transcribe so at the
very least if this works
it doesn't work on the core problem if
i'm right about what the core problem is
um and it's also it remains
to be demonstrated that there's anything
useful about the telomere
elongation that's being measured in fact
there's a way
again i'm talking about a paper i
haven't deeply read but um there's a way
in which that could be an artifact and
not really
a measure of anything the paper yarn
deeply read being the hyperbaric oxygen
therapy
for that um zach just quickly put this
up yeah so this is your paper
with debbie from 2002. yeah and i think
the uh histological entropy is even here
right there entropy
yeah entropy which again if i had it to
do over i would call epigenetic entropy
the meaning is the same i always loved
histological entropy as not as a process
so much
right i liked it more back then when i
was younger right
exactly but uh yeah i i
i think it's a great uh great phrase but
i understand why you
would would rather it be epigenetic
entropy i think
um you're talking it's more fundamental
it's earlier in the
in the pathway well i think it was
misinterpreted i think the term so there
are a lot of bad
hypotheses of senescence based on
entropy right people have noticed oh the
body gets more chaotic over time i
actually hadn't it hadn't occurred to me
that that was
the problem yeah so i think people read
it as a kind of oh another one of those
garbage arguments and the answer is no
this is a very specific argument about
information
yeah yeah where is that information it's
epigenetic information okay
and so i i will say i haven't manifests
in the histological tissues perhaps but
yeah right right right uh yeah that's
right it is histological
there's nothing wrong with the term in
terms of its meaning there's wrong it's
wrong in terms of
what i think people read it to mean but
um i know that david sinclair
at harvard has picked up this threat
it's an important part of his argument
so
um anyway i don't i don't know him i
don't recognize the name
he's uh a senescence researcher he's
been on
uh various podcasts that we know and
things
okay so anyway
um i have a cousin who believes that men
have periods and believes that your
videos are transphobic
please still man the argument for this
and give scientific argument against
steel man the argument that we're
transphobic
um well the standard in the argument
that men have periods
so you know we we have been consistent
and clear that we do not think that
trans is a fiction
we we know trans people we count trans
people among our friends
and um we understand that
while sex is a
a binary effectively a binary going back
to the
anise anisogamy of two very different
gamete types
that in our lineage is 500 million years
old at least uninterrupted
that the manifestation of individual
bodies in regard to what sex they are
are more complex and therefore some
can be somewhat messier and that there
can be
a disconnect between say your actual sex
your actual sex
which is to say you know the gametes
that you produce and your chromosomal
sex which in mammals and birds
um is um is determining what sex you are
and your anatomical and physiological
sex like the you know the primary and
secondary sex characteristics that um
are revealed on your body and um
and also endocrinologically and then
also the sex
of your brain and this is where things
get more and more fuzzy
you know male and female brains are on
average different in some regards i
can't remember which way it goes but
one i should look it up but one one sex
of brain tends to have more white matter
and one sex of brain tends to have more
gray matter for instance
um so you know there are average
differences with yes ton of overlap
between them
but it is it is quite possible given the
complexity and length of development
for signals to get mixed
and for someone to be an actual male for
instance with the brain that feels so
female that it is um irreconcilable for
them to live as a male
and so basically for the for their their
feeling of their own sex in their brain
to be
not the sex that they are and therefore
to live their best live
lives to live their best life um to live
as the sex that they are not and
therefore to be
um you know trans
to be to be nice to be respectful i
am fine calling a person i guess i've
used the wrong example but someone who
is actually female
who thinks that who really feels in
their brain that they need to live as a
man
that that trans man will continue
to have periods probably um
frankly if they're continuing to have
periods they probably aren't fully
transitioned because
um once you're on testosterone you
probably are not continuing to have
periods although
you know i don't know enough about the
various endocrinological
uh things to know that for sure um i
would not
call such a person a man they're not a
man they're a trans man
and that is a sign of respect and i'll
be happy to use he him pronouns with
such a person
but at base that person is a biological
female
because biological females are the
people who have periods
not men all right so
i agree with what you said interact very
carefully um i think we can say it
very simply great let's do it okay so
what i would say is trans is a real
phenomenon it is an ancient phenomenon
it is one that we see
in many different cultures there are uh
allowances for such things and the
expectation that they will happen
sorry so i want you to i'm going to have
you go back and do this briefly again
but let me just
interrupt right there and say we in fact
know that trans is not just
real and ancient but is um has many
different causes it's actually multiple
things so for instance
there's a small population and i think
it is haiti with what is now understood
to be a very real genetic variant
that produces transness such that the
rate of trans people in this one village
in haiti is sky
high compared to you know every place
else where it's a tiny fraction of one
percent
so i think that genetic variant is
unknown in the rest of the world for
instance but so you know in this
particular part of haiti
um trans is understood to be caused by a
particular genetic
unknown and no reason to believe it
exists right um in other words it's not
typically caused by genes as far as we
know um
okay so by some genetic variant start
again with your brief okay explanation
trans
is ancient natural and there
are allowances for it in many cultures
as a result
when a person is trans
they arrive there by self-designation
by reporting features of their
personality that would tell us that
their
mind feels more female even though their
body is male
and in such a case the right thing to do
is to treat them as a man
for some intents and purposes and that's
the point it's not all intents and
purposes that's why we are fighting over
the term
man right what intents and purposes well
let's just say
loosely social insofar as it doesn't
cause a bigger problem somewhere else
they're not a man from the point of view
of a karyotype from the point of view
of their doctor right they are
a man from the perspective of
social interaction and our treatment and
then we run into
again places where we can't be so simple
about it when we get
to sexed bathrooms
sports prison other things where
we actually have to make a call and the
answer is not simple right
so anyway this is for um
survivors of domestic violence sure like
there there is a just like there is a
reason
for um non-symmetrical protections for
women
under the law there is a reason for
women to have spaces
which men cannot enter and um
this is an obvious potential way to game
that
and we know that even though the vast
majority of people
who are actually trans would never be
doing that that it has happened
right so the simple version the steel
man version is
trans is natural that means that there
are
uh people who are born female who
transition to male who
um may continue to have periods
and they should be treated as men where
practical
right but not everything that's where
we part ways with the idea that men can
have periods because that's absurd
period
is a a biological
phenomenon there's a reason that it
strikes the mind is inconsistent to hear
that and the mind is not incorrect to
register that inconsistency
so yeah no i mean how do we know that we
are not transphobic
because we've just told you a that we've
had
many trans students that we get on well
with them
that we regard trans as a natural and
ancient phenomenon that cultures
have incorporated for uh well
thousands of years and how could we
possibly be transphobic if that's what
we're saying that doesn't mean we're not
wrong about stuff but
it's in the idea that we are somehow
hostile to transness is
no i think that's being too generous um
a transphobia
is a term that doesn't mean what it
seems to me
actual transphobia um which i haven't
exactly run into
would be it's not real at all there is
there is
there is no there is
no way to be thinking about anyone being
trans
um uh i don't i don't even know what it
would sound like honestly so i'm not
i'm not even sure i think that the word
has
any meaning honestly outside of the
trans rights activists
who use it as a weapon it's used as a
bludgeon um
to and so almost anyone who is wielding
the term transphobia
at this point i would say no you are
reality phobic
i'm not transphobic you are reality
phobic uh let us
let us lay out for you what is actually
true
and where the points are that we could
reasonably disagree
and if if you really believe
that a period which is the result of
a failed fertilization of an egg event
which is as female as fundamentally
female a process
as can possibly be is something that
could be happening in a male body
then you need a better education we
don't need to
admit that we're transphobic you need to
admit that you're reality-phobic
i think you nailed it okay all right
uh do you know who joel kotkin is i
don't think so i don't either
joel cutken we are told has done quite a
bit on neo-feudalism
that big tech act as oligarchs incoming
inequality is high and social mobility
is low
do you have thoughts um from that brief
blurb
um sounds potentially right but uh
neither of us
know the name yeah i would say
you know neo-feudalism is going to be
like
fascism where there are going to be
elements of it all over the place and
the ones you point to here in this
question
certainly are worthy of
asking this question but you're not
going to find all of the elements
um so maybe by calling it neo-feudalism
you you rescue yourself from
that predicament but um but yeah there's
definitely some analogy to be made
it's gonna fall apart the finer grain
you get
okay just one one more quick question
because i doubt you will answer it but i
think we should read it before we move
to this hour's questions
for a little bit anyway you talked about
a video that was pulled from youtube in
a few hours what is the title and where
is it available
i don't remember the title actually um i
don't
well i mean i could presumably find it
if you wanted to share it
but um part of part of the conversation
that we had
was um about whether or not
um whether or not we actually
i mean amazingly bizarrely that we live
in this world right now
uh feel that we can talk about it yeah
right so what do you think if i find out
which i'm about to be able to do here i
think in my notes
here's why i don't want to do it okay
that's what i thought first of all i
think you'd probably
find it from what we've said but um well
but
no there's actually there's a few out
there there's a couple yeah there's a
few uh
what i would like to do i believe that
our responsibility
and i don't believe that this is a
requirement
of our contractual interaction with
google
such as it is but i believe that our the
moral requirement given who we are and
what we do
is that we present this material in
context
and we do some work to make it clear
why certain claims you know why the
claims have
the status that they do right and so
anyway i would like to figure out that
this is safe enough to engage in
and um to engage in it
properly and you know i don't think
we're going to be able to establish that
you know google's not going to tell us
it's safe so we're going to have to take
the risk
but i would like not to
[Music]
wow that's a lot of barking i would like
not to
set people to looking at this some
people will have
tools to evaluate it um but others will
not and i think to the extent that we
are bringing
attention to it we should bring
attention with the proper tools to
figure out what it means
good okay i do not have a line
here to tell me where the new hours
questions start and
our producer has just gone to quiet the
dog um
i think i'm on it zach you're back now
huh um i think this is the first
question in the next hour
science is the best tool yeah science is
the best tool to find out how the world
is
including in social science we can make
descriptive claims about the objective
and subjective
no anti-positivism or interpretivism
what do you think much love
yeah i mean at some level you know that
sounds like an audacious claim but the
thing is
this is the the basic essence of
figuring out
what's true it's the best mechanism we
have and that's not to say
that it doesn't need upgrading i have
argued
many times that we have gotten much
better at figuring out what's true
in the context of the simple sciences
simple sciences not being easy sciences
sometimes they're much harder but
fundamental sciences fundamental
sciences yeah physics
chemistry we've done a really good job
of figuring out to a high
degree of certainty and specificity
how things work we are much earlier in
the process
of figuring out complex systems
especially complex adaptive systems
and there is a alteration a
philosophical alteration you need to
make
to the scientific method in its context
in order to do complex systems well but
that said you know there are patterns
that's the only thing that we can notice
that we can discuss
figuring out how those patterns work
requires a method
we don't have a better method nor is
there any reason to think that there is
a better method than fundamentally a
scientific approach in which you
attempt to falsify hypotheses and that
which is left standing after all such
attempts is
the model that we continue forward with
so
yeah basically the answer to your
question i think is yes
all right next question how did
concealed ovulation evolve
did this from echo did we move from male
selecting for females for fertility
women historically having few ovulations
to females selecting for males
does concealed ovulation imply more male
competition
so um just to knock off a few of the a
little bit of the low-hanging fruit here
does concealed ovulation apply more male
competition
no i think it implies um exactly as the
previous question
in this line of thinking suggests um
that you now have
um that you basically now have choice
going both directions
um and that effectively
uh when ovulation when it's clear from
the outside when males can tell when a
female is at her most fertile
she is more easily controlled by males
who have an interest in controlling the
reproductive
um periods and just reproduction
reproductive capacity of females
and so you know this goes back to well
the classic paper
on the evolution of mating systems uh
emily and oring from 1977
which may even be called the evolution
of painting systems many systems being
those things that describe you know are
you you in a monogamous society where
you have one female to one male
poliginis one male to multiple females
polyandrous
one female to multi multiple males or
so-called promiscuous which in human
modern human terms who would call
polyamory sort of a free-for-all
so all of those are known mating systems
polygony being by far the most common
among mammals monogamy being next most
common
and polyandry and promiscuity being
very very rare monogamy is pretty rare
as well
but in a traditional system you have
males competing among
in a polygenic system of males competing
between
um each other amongst each other for
access to females and females in most
situations get to choose
and as you move more and more towards
monogamy
you have competition within both sexes
for access to the other sex and also
choice
by both sexes of the other sex and
as one of the ways that females
um physiologically with no conscious
choice at all of course
involved can effectively move a system
away from polygyny towards monogamy
which is good for almost everyone except
a few very powerful males
is to make their own reproduction less
controllable by males
and how do you make it less controllable
you make it less obvious you make it
less discernible
so concealment of ovulation is one way
obviously to make
your fertile period less less obvious
what is the mechanism i have no idea
um well let me uh again try to
i think that's a a plus lesson in
this uh this set of questions but this
can be hard to follow but if you think
about it this way
males have an evolutionary incentive to
try to dominate the reproductive output
of as many females as they can
and if you imagine a system in which
males are able to spot when females are
fertile which is true in most creatures
they a male a powerful male will move
from one
one female to the next at her fertile
period and fertilize each of them
and basically fend off competing males
so um
to prevent that a system evolves in this
case
the invisibility so that a male who
attempted that
might succeed in mating with but would
not necessarily succeed in fertilizing
therefore
the best male strategy even for a
powerful male will be to invest in an
individual female
so that he has sex with her when she's
fertile even if neither of them know
when that
is and so anyway i'd say it's a
very positive thing and i agree with
your
your point about control that to it to
the extent that this was concealed to
the outside world
but not to the woman herself then
coercion might force a woman to cough
that information
up which would then reinstitute the
system in which powerful males
had the ability to fertilize many
females and the downside of that
well there is you know whenever i talked
about this in classrooms
i would have a few young women saying i
kind of know and i think you know and
and there there is there is a kind of no
um in terms of sort of peak fertility
um for a lot of women um but it's still
nowhere close to obvious the way it is
in all of our primate relatives
it's not close and it's also not precise
in other words we're talking about a
number of hours
and the fact of having a general sense
of when it is is not the same thing as
knowing when you're fertile
also i would say that we know we moderns
know a tremendous amount
more about things like fertility and how
long these periods are
and so to the degree that there is some
detectable thing
it is also um embedded in a system
in which a woman knows that there's
something to look for right
uh it's based on extent metrics right
and so anyway yes i
i got the same pushback on that point uh
every time and it i think it means less
than
than people imagine that it does but in
any case
bottom line message here is that there's
a fascinating
you know i would say mating systems is
one of the places that evolutionary
biology has done
reasonably well that we have understood
a great deal about this
and you know it was a lot to emily
noring and their
you know initial foray yeah it's just
brilliant classic papers
it's a really important um insight but i
would also point out
you said monogamy is rare in mammals
i said mammals i said that i was very
clear i thought i thought you just said
it was rare
nope in mammals it's extraordinarily
rare right um
okay not rare exactly birds and
this has everything to do uh you know to
the extent that you have the sense
that um monogamy is
not evolutionarily favored the reason
that it's rare
in mammals has to do with the way
mammals reproduce which causes males
not to have high certainty of paternity
because pregnancy is long
whereas eggs bird eggs are fertilized
right before
the shell is put on right before they
are laid and so a
bird a male bird is in a much better
position to know how likely it is
that he is the father of any given egg
um and in the case that males have high
uh certainty of paternity investing is
favored
right so in birds we have something like
85 percent of species
have some degree of monogamy right that
can be inside of a season or it can be
lifelong but
and you know it's monogamy is never
perfect in these systems when we check
genetically but
um but anyway the point is actually
selection
favors monogamy when certainty of
paternity is high
and it is the decrease in certainty of
paternity in a mammal
system that causes it to be the rare
outcome yeah um okay i've lost my mouse
again
um zach but if you would just show my
screen for a moment and then see if you
can return me to
where i need to be so this is just this
is the paper we've been talking about
emilyn and orang published in 1977
um ecology sexual selection and the
evolution of many systems
uh out it's hard for
you and me at this point to know how
hard to access it actually is because
it's sort of in our blood and has been
for so long
but it i think this paper always struck
me you know we ran into it first
almost two decades after it was written
um but has always struck me as
so clear and so precise and concise and
just
brilliantly done that
it's it's worth going to if you're
interested in
this kind of talk about sort of what
ecological conditions and for humans
ecological conditions can include
the density of the city you live in and
what kinds of resources are around you
might lead to different kinds of mating
systems like monogamy versus palliation
long as we're here the simple thing
you're looking for in that paper
is females distribute themselves across
a landscape
based on the distribution of resources
which tends to drive them apart that is
to say
a competition for food will cause
females not to want to be foraging right
next to each other now the distribution
of food can be patchy which affects that
but basically
food competition drives females apart
predator competition drives females
together
females space themselves based on the
tension of these two parameters and then
males
pick a strategy based on how females are
distributed around
the uh the landscape and what their
reproductive parameters are which varies
if they are synchronized in their
fertility
asynchronous uh concealed ovulation etc
so
unless you're jakana which i'm not good
okay then we don't have to talk about
them good or a foul wrote
right well i'm also not not a fouler
yeah i guess you're not nope that's good
can you comment on the trump team's
progress
in pennsylvania it's getting weird and
everyone except tim poole and senk
i think it's ungar so yeah that's
spelled weird and his name
how is it pronounced i think it's jane
cugar
is pretending it's not happening um i
really can't
i have been ignoring it uh yeah i have
to say i'm not following it uh i agree
with your first sentence it's getting
it's getting weird yeah um you know i
have the sense that this is
over um but obviously
that's not exactly where we are yeah
contrarian perhaps because the low
threshold speed limit the low posted
speed limit that we talked about in the
last hour
be a shape of institutional racism for
instance new york stop and frisk
a hundred percent oh yeah exactly right
no in fact that was that was you're
trying to imply yeah in fact i heard
myself not include blacks as one of the
categories of people you might choose to
pull over
i did too son of a [ __ ] but yeah um but
yeah
of course yeah that's a classic yeah
that's
that's that's exactly it's one of the
ways that you know
a rule that's not bigoted allows bigoted
people
to enforce it in a bigoted manner um so
how
how do we make rules and laws uh that
preclude that from happening that's
tough
but oh it has to be done we have to
figure out how yeah
okay we're going to get through a couple
more we got a 200 question here we're
going to get through uh
yep oh it's a different currency okay um
well we're going to get through that one
anyway because it's a good question
so four more here how many plans are on
hold for you all due to covid
how is one to live without pursuing
certain goals if covet is closing off
options it seems too much to take in
more risk taking how do you make the
best of it i live alone right now for
context
i am about as introverted and capable of
spending long periods of time alone
as anyone i've ever met having spent
long periods of time nearly alone on an
island off the coast of madagascar which
is itself off the coast of africa for
many many many months when i was doing
my graduate research
and i cannot imagine how
people are staying fully mentally
healthy
if they're living alone right now it's
really
really hard and we are we are
both so lucky to have the four of us who
as we
said early and it's still true you know
we have four people living together who
both
who not only love each other but also
continue to like each other
um plus we have four animals non-human
animals with whom we share
space and we live in nature and um
so that we can get outside even in those
at those moments when
stupidly early on the parks were closed
etc um
so in that way we are incredibly lucky
and we know that most people are not
most people do not have that um that
combination of things
that are making this um relatively easy
that said this isn't easy
it's not easy at all it's hard and um
boy we watched we watched so many things
that we had planned just fall
off um in march the cancellation of
we were supposed to go to new orleans we
were supposed to go to princeton to give
a talk we were supposed to go
to um i was supposed to be at princeton
again
this month i think we were supposed to
go to bucknell there were all sorts of
we were supposed to be
yeah there were there were just all
sorts of events that we were supposed to
go to to speak at
to be at uh and that involve
would have involved not just seeing more
of the world which as we have said over
and over and over again is one of the
you know it's one of the joys of life
but it's also one of the ways to make
sure that your model
is is not becoming out of date or or
provincial
and but it's also one of the ways to
meet so many people that you wouldn't
otherwise have an opportunity to meet so
all of our lives are becoming more
restricted more provincial
because we're not able to do that
anymore that said would we have chosen
to start live streaming
when we did have we not suddenly been in
lockdown i don't know
you know very well maybe not
uh in part uh we saw
what we perceived in late february and
uh early march as such an abundance of
bad information
and terrible talking points and uh
world views that were inconsistent
internally with regard to covid
that we thought you know we we actually
have some insight here
we're going to take the airwaves as it
were and start talking about it
and i'm not sure what would have been
the impetus
uh absent that so uh that is
there are certainly also good things
that have emerged um for us but
um at the moment most of the plans that
we
would have had most of the places who
would have been going now
hadn't even made it to the calendar yet
so i'm sure this is true for most people
who who
go places who were invited to go places
that
we had things in april may june july
you know through now cancelled but no
new plans have been made
and so who knows what the winter and
spring could be looking like
right now absent absent the lockdowns
and um you know one one additional
effect
is that our book has been the
publication date for our book has been
delayed
um because in part in large part
apparently because
of um supply and delays
in terms of paper and printing delays
for
uh for for for the printers and so you
know this book that was supposed to come
out in the spring of 2021 is now going
to come out in september of 2021
now i will say which is both
disappointing but also maybe by that
point we'll all be out from under this
thing and we'll be able to actually
travel
and do you know and and do events around
the book
and maybe meet many of you who we
otherwise wouldn't have met
but it's a it's a [ __ ] yeah it's
chaos i will say because of the way
we've written the book
it will still remain true even given the
delay
um yeah although as you know i went back
in and i was like well we gotta add
something about koben don't we all right
go boy yep yeah um but i would say look
there's
there's a couple things one this has
been catastrophic at some levels
two as heather points out it has caused
innovation
three there's diminishing returns on the
innovation the more months
we go on like this um the less there is
to be learned each month
um four i'm concerned as hell that we
are now botching the analysis of what's
really in our collective interest
because this has now been so thoroughly
politicized that um
we are not in agreement about what is
taking place and given
what uh the consensus seems to be about
what is taking place we are not in
agreement about what the rational
policy response would be we've got to
get out of that situation we've got to
get to a place where we can actually
talk
cost benefit you know deaths caused by
lockdown versus deaths caused by
not locking down all these things have
to be compared and there's a way to do
it but we're just not doing it
we're playing team games instead
what is your opinion on democracy in the
workplace eg worker co-ops
i'm not sure i would have thought of
worker co-ops being democracy in the
workplace per se
yeah um so i'm not sure exactly what the
what the person is
is getting at i think uh you know the
worker co-ops that i'm most familiar
with are food co-ops
um which we've we've always been members
of whatever food co-ops
are wherever we live um and
they seem to work really effectively
they're you know they tend to be small
organizations with very left-leaning
individuals who are therefore somewhat
uh susceptible to capture to ideological
capture and we we've seen that long
before
the current moment in um i think we even
saw that in ann arbor but we certainly
saw in olympia
yep um yeah i'd say it works very
differently for different kinds of
organizations
you know in a food co-op uh at least for
a while it works in your favor
it results in you know food that's less
likely to be
compromised by pesticides and and other
such things and you know
it it's going to increase the price but
um
in terms of the harm you know if
if pesticides are not harmful and
there's no reason to think that that
would be the case but if it was the case
it wouldn't hurt you to eat things that
didn't have them they're not like a
nutrient so you know the the bent
of a food co-op tends to work uh
in the direction of the health of the
people who shop there
um but as you point out it can extend to
other things and we can start
battling about you know whether they
should divest from israel
right or whether the you know tortillas
are culturally appropriative based on
you know
who owned the shop that pressed them or
whatever so you know there's a danger
but
you scale this up you know what does
democracy look like in a larger entity
you know well frankly it looks like you
know
penguin canada having an allergic
reaction
to the publication of a book by a highly
respected author who you know
i don't know what his second tweet was
going to sell a huge number of books and
is therefore good for the bottom line of
the business on whom these people depend
for their salaries
right um so anyway obviously it should
not be
up to a bunch of employees who want to
shut down certain
schools of thought to decide what a
publisher can publish the answer is the
publisher
could publish things frankly that the
publisher doesn't believe are
true it should publish them so that you
know if these arguments are
viable that we can have the debate about
what they are and in the case of
peterson this is
so freaking insane if you look at what
his first 12 rules were
yeah you know it's
obviously in the interest of the
well-being of the people that he's
publishing the book
for allow me to take this moment to say
publicly also that i have always stopped
to pet cats when i see them on the
street yes you have
you've been you've been on that rule
since the beginning exactly
two more questions hi from an
evolutionary standpoint what do you
think
is the most fundamental morale or moral
that should be
or ethical rule of our society for
instance is it the golden rule
is it consent my first thought
reading this is that we have this list
of um
twelve things that we say associate
eight
twelve twelve i said twelve i was
thinking of the twelve days of christmas
last time it's terrible
um eight things associated with the
eight nights of hanukkah
that have seemed fairly central
to running a
a good and fair society and they
actually formed the epilogue of our book
and
one of them is in fact the goldman role
and no one of them is not consent
um because it seems to me that consent
is uh is
a sub issue um that as soon as you make
it into a static rule it's going to be
gamed
yeah so uh you know certainly golden
rule
stands you know it's a candidate i would
say that there's a deeper
principle than all of it but in some
sense i'm thrown by your asking from an
evolutionary standpoint because
evolution is perfectly immoral
and there are places where we are
to absolutely reject what it wants for
us but
the deepest one i would say is that
life is an incredibly precious gift
human life is the most
amazing privilege a person
can have right not only do you get to
live and experience life but you also
get to understand
meaning and to um
to to live fully in a way that other
creatures
can't there's some aspect of the
experience that they don't have access
to so in any case
i guess my point would be given what it
is
seems to me that we are morally
obligated
to see how many people we can
give that experience and while that will
initially sound like a frightening
argument in favor of large populations
it is in fact the opposite because in
order
to give the maximum number of people the
experience of being a human being who is
liberated by
sufficient well-being that they can
dedicate themselves to things of true
meaning
you have to live in a way that we do not
degrade the planet as we go
and so the large number of people that
we would give this experience would be
a human population that could go on
indefinitely because we are being
careful enough with the resource
that we have been been granted so
anyway i think that's the highest
principle is you know
are we working towards leaving this
opportunity as good as we found it or
better
so that as many generations of us can
experience it as possible and
if we're not doing that then we are
falling down on our obligation
to to ourselves and
to our lineage one more question
and then we will end for this week what
role do dreams play evolutionarily
and how does the mind quantify dreams
prior to the knowledge of language
um well this is a funny one i'm gonna
hold back a little bit because there is
a major
theoretical puzzle piece to be put in
place and you know
deep at the end of a q a doesn't seem
the place to to unveil it but
i will say a we know that dreams are
widespread
that is to say amongst creed creatures
b we know what kinds of creatures seem
to have
to have dreams it's a little hard to
nail down exactly what
what's going on because we don't read
the brain that easily but we've got a
lot of
correlative evidence that tells us that
this happens
they are clearly adaptive because they
are expensive
um to the extent that they are expensive
they have to be paying their freight
and then some in order to have uh to
have evolved
we have reason to think that they are
convergently evolved multiple times
that's really interesting so it
suggests that the utility of dreams is
large enough that it's been discovered
in many different clades or at least
several different clades
and so anyway the answer is for some
reason
the brain makes movies at night one
learns a lot about the type of movies if
if you experiment with lucid dreaming
you'll discover a lot about your dreams
and there's certainly a tremendous
amount of value in just simply trying to
remember
your dreams there's often good stuff you
know obviously
uh freud and young and many others have
recognized
the deep connection of these things to
our
our capacities and our waking life so
anyway yes a deep evolutionary story is
there to be unearthed and it's connected
to some very
surprising other things and
stay tuned we will get there as soon as
possible hopefully the world will open
back up and
we can take some of these things
into appropriate halls and give a decent
presentation on it that's right that
would be wonderful
i look forward to that moment well that
is it for today but let us reiterate a
few
things that are going on soon tomorrow
at 11 a.m pacific less than 24 hours
from now we will be doing our once
monthly private q a which you can get
access to by joining at my patreon
if you join my patreon you will also
get access to a 20
off um code
for our new merchandise shop
which is at teespring store slash
dark dash horse dash podcast
if you don't join either our patreons
you can use the code thankful all caps
through monday for 15 off you can join
brett's patreon or
mine for access to a discord server
where people are having good
conversations and at brett's patreon
you can also at higher monetary amounts
get access to conversations that he has
on the first
saturday and sunday of the month which
will be next weekend would have been
awesome yeah so actually the 100 one
will be before our next live stream
right before our next live stream
next saturday next saturday right i will
post the
i sent the promo code to my patrons
yesterday but i now realize if you
joined now you wouldn't
see it so that's a reason for me to post
it rather than send it so i will post it
to my patreon so if you join
my patreon you'll have access to it also
um i don't know like subscribe notify
yup be well rock on
um enjoy the end of november yeah enjoy
the end of doing it why not what else
are you gonna do
yes enjoy things while you can and get
outdoors
all right be well everyone
you